good afternoon
today we announce criminal charges
against the conspiracy of russian
military intelligence officers
who stand accused of conducting the most
disruptive
and destructive series of computer
attacks
ever attributed to a single group
i'm joined here today in this
announcement by fbi deputy director dave
baudic
by the u.s attorney for the western
district of pennsylvania scott brady
and by the special agent in charge of
the pittsburgh field office
mike chris christman
in the past three years alone the
department has charged computer
intrusions
or taken legal actions three months
alone sorry
we're taking legal action related to the
activities of china
iran and north korea each of these cases
charged significant and malicious
conduct that we have called
out in part to reinforce norms of
responsible nation-state behavior
in cyberspace but as this case shows
no country has weaponized its cyber
capabilities
as maliciously and irresponsibly as
russia wantonly causing
unprecedented collateral damage to
pursue small
tactical advantages and fits of spite
the defendants in this case were all
members of the military unit
74455 of the russian main intelligence
directorate
known as the gru the department
previously charged members of this same
unit also known to cyber security
researchers
as the sand worm team for their role in
russia's efforts to interfere with the
2016 u.s elections
we make no election interference
allegations here
rather today's charges illustrate how
unit 74455
election activities were but one part
of the work of a persistent
sophisticated hacking group
busy sabotaging perceived enemies or
detractors of the russian federation
regardless of the consequences to
innocent bystanders
or their destabilizing effect
six current and former officers in unit
74455 are accused of the following
disruptive and destructive attacks
alleged in the indictment
in december of 2015 and 2016 the
conspirators launched destructive
malware attacks against the electric
power grid in the ukraine
these were the first reported
destructive malware attacks against the
control systems
of civilian critical infrastructure
these attacks turned out the lights
and turned off the heat in the middle of
the eastern european winter
as the lives of hundreds of thousands of
ukrainian men women and children
went dark and cold from there the
conspirators destructive path
still putatively aimed at the ukraine
widened to encompass virtually the whole
world
in what is commonly referred to as the
most destructive and costly
cyber attack ever the conspirators
unleashed the not petya malware
although it masqueraded as ransomware
designed to extort money
this was a false flag the conspirators
designed the malware to spread with
devastating
and indiscriminate alacrity bringing
down entire networks in seconds
and searching for remote computer
connections through which to attack
additional innocent victims
all without hope of recovery or repair
the entirely foreseeable result was that
the worm quickly spread globally
shutting down companies and inflicting
immense financial harm
this irresponsible conduct impaired the
ability of companies in critical sectors
such as transportation and health care
to provide services to the public not
only in the ukraine
but as far away as western pennsylvania
as alleged for just three u.s related
victims
three of at least hundreds of victims
worldwide
the damages exceeded one billion dollars
rather than express remorse for the
damage they inflicted against victims
worldwide
the conspirators callously celebrated
their success
next the conspirators turn their sights
on the winter olympics
a forum where the international
community despite recurring conflict
comes together to celebrate the common
pursuit
of physical prowess and mental toughness
the conspirators feeling the
embarrassment of international penalties
related to russia's state-sponsored
doping program
that is cheating took it upon themselves
to undermine the games
their cyber attack combined the
emotional maturity of a petulant child
with the resources of a nation-state
they conducted spearfishing campaigns
against south korea the host of the
winter games
as well as the international olympic
committee olympic partners and athletes
then during the opening ceremony they
launched the olympic destroyer malware
which deleted data from thousands of
computers supporting the games
rendering them inoperable although the
conspirators took steps to pin the
olympic destroyer attack on north korea
this second false flag attempt failed
cyber security researchers ultimately
attributed the san
the attack to the sand worm team as do
we today
these destructive and disruptive malware
attacks and related preparations
were not the conspirators only malicious
conduct alleged in the indictment
the conspirators also supported hack and
leak operations in the days leading up
to the 2017 french elections
and the conspirators continued their
disrupting attacks as recently as
october 19th
targeting government and non-government
websites in
the country of georgia today's
allegations
in their entirety provide a useful lens
for evaluating russia's offer two weeks
ago for a reset
in cyber relations between the russia
and the united states
russia is certainly right that
technologically sophisticated nations
that aspire to lead
have a special responsibility to secure
the world order
and contribute to widely accepted norms
peace and security
that's what we're doing here today
but this indictment lays bare russia's
use of its cyber capabilities to
destabilize
and interfere with the domestic
political and economic systems
of other countries thus providing a cold
reminder
of why its proposal is nothing more than
dishonest
rhetoric and cynical and cheap
propaganda
before i wrap up my remarks i'd like to
thank the team of prosecutors and fbi
agents
whose diligence and perseverance has led
to these charges
and to the kind of evidence that we can
use to prove
these charges in open court i'd like to
express the department's appreciation
for assistance from the private sector
such as cisco's telus intelligence group
facebook google
and twitter and investigating and
disrupting this cyber threat
we also appreciate the hard work and
dedication of our four
foreign law enforcement and intelligence
partners
in countries including the ukraine
georgia south korea the united kingdom
and new zealand who have also pursued
these conspirators after attacks and
intrusions within their own countries
or otherwise assisted in our
investigation
all these partnerships send a clear
message that responsible nations in the
private sector are prepared
to work together to defend against and
disrupt significant
cyber threats now i'll turn the podium
over
to the u.s attorney from the western
district of pennsylvania to go over the
charges
in more detail scott
thank you john good afternoon i'm scott
brady i'm the u.s attorney for the
western district of pennsylvania
today my colleagues and i are pleased to
announce that a federal grand jury in
pittsburgh pennsylvania
returned a seven-count indictment
charging six russian military
intelligence officers
for their roles in some of the most
destructive most costly
and most egregious cyber attacks ever
known the defendants were all officers
within military unit 74455
of the russia main intelligence
directorate also known as the gru
unit 74455 is well known to the
department of justice and to the fbi
for among other things its role in
russia's efforts to interfere in the
2016 u.s elections
portions of which were initially
investigated by the western district of
pennsylvania
with our partners from the national
security division and the fbi's
pittsburgh field office
the indictment unsealed today reveals
the russian government's global campaign
of disruption interference and
destabilization
against strategic adversaries across
three continents
as outlined by aag demers the crimes
committed by these defendants
and unit 74455
are truly breathtaking in their scope
scale
and impact
aag dimers spoke to the broader
geopolitical implications of the gru's
campaign
i want to speak for a moment about the
victims in this case
while the alleged perpetrators of these
crimes were russian government officials
the victims who suffered real harm as a
result of these crimes
were often ordinary citizens and
businesses around the world
these are citizens and businesses that
rely on such things
as electricity for warmth during a cold
ukrainian winter
a reliable banking system as a
foundation for a stable economy
untainted elections free from
interference by foreign adversaries
the opportunity to participate in a
traditionally non-political event like
the olympics
and access to fundamentally sound
hospitals for life-saving medical care
to name just a few the devastating
crimes allegedly committed by these
defendants and unit seven
four four five five co-conspirators
harmed ordinary people around the world
including in my district in western
pennsylvania
as a result of the nutpecia malware
attack heritage valley health systems
which provides health care to tens of
thousands in western pennsylvania
lost access to their mission-critical
computer systems
such as those used for cardiology
nuclear medicine
radiology and surgery their hard drives
at 80 medical facilities were encrypted
workstations were locked patient lists
medical patient history
examination files and laboratory records
were inaccessible
while heritage valley spent more than 2
million responding to and recovering
from the attack
the disruption of [ __ ] health care to
patients cannot be quantified monetarily
additionally a fedex subsidiary spent
approximately 400 million
responding to and recovering from
notepatchy attack on its computer
systems
and a large u.s pharmaceutical
manufacturer spent in excess of 500
million
and these are just three of the hundreds
of victims of nutpecia worldwide
these are not acts of traditional spying
against governments
instead these are crimes committed by
russian government officials
against real victims who suffered real
harm
my colleagues and i on this stage have
an obligation to hold accountable those
who commit crimes
no matter where they reside and no
matter for whom they work
in an effort to seek justice on behalf
of the victims of these crimes
let me talk briefly about the charges in
the seven count indictment
the defendants are charged in count one
with engaging in an ongoing and
wide-ranging conspiracy
to hack into computers steal information
such as network credentials
and cause significant damage to the
networks through the
deployment of malicious code otherwise
known as malware
the defendants are charged account two
with conspiracy to commit wire fraud
this offense consists of conspiring to
use stolen authentication credentials
to gain access to and move laterally
within victims networks
as well as the transmission of spear
phishing emails
designed to deceive the victim into
clicking on a malicious link or
attachment
to gain unauthorized access to victims
computer networks
counts three and four charge the
defendants with substantive counts of
wire fraud
associated with the transmission of the
nutpecia malware
through the computer systems of heritage
valley health systems
in the western district of pennsylvania
using stolen authentication credentials
to move to other parts of the network
count five charges the defendants with a
substantive count of computer fraud
relating to the transmission of the
nutpecia malware on the heritage valley
health system computer network
and causing damage to that network
finally count six and seven charge the
defendants with
aggravated identity theft that means
they illegally obtained
identifying information including
usernames and passwords
used by real persons and exploited it to
further their hacking activity
all of the countries named in the
indictment share the ideals of a free
society
based on national sovereignty ordered
liberty
the rule of law and free and fair
elections
for these reasons they also share a
common threat
russia a country that will stop at
nothing to destroy those ideals
and instill a sense of instability in
its adversaries
the indictment unsealed today was only
made possible by the willingness
of countries to come together and share
information and evidence associated with
these attacks
in the western district of pennsylvania
in conjunction with our partners at nsd
and fbi
we continue to develop this new paradigm
involving
unprecedented levels of collaboration
with our foreign law enforcement
partners
in the ongoing fight against cyber crime
whether committed by
transnational organized crime groups or
nation-state groups such as the russian
gru
in closing i want to thank the assistant
u.s attorneys for my office and the
trial attorneys from the national
security division
for their incredible work on this case
we in the western district of
pennsylvania value the long and trusted
working relationship with nsd
under aag demurs leadership i also want
to thank all the agents from the fbi's
pittsburgh
oklahoma and atlanta field offices
the fbi legal attache offices around the
world who contributed to this
investigation
fbi cyber division at fbi headquarters
and the assistance we receive from our
foreign partners from victims
and from those in cyber security private
industry
now i will turn the podium over to fbi
deputy director david bowditch
good afternoon we're here to turn a
spotlight
on the numerous destructive cyber
attacks
which are perpetrated by the gru
which as you've heard is russia is the
russian military's
intelligence agency this activity went
well beyond
traditional intelligence collection the
gru
targeted the global energy sector the
international political groups
hospitals and even the olympics
time and again russia has made it clear
they will not
abide by accepted norms and instead
they intend to continue their
destructive
and destabilizing cyber behavior
of course this threat is not new we've
been fighting the cyber threat for years
now
addressing hacked after hack as our
adversaries continue to escalate
their crimes and use their capabilities
not just to gather intelligence but also
to disrupt
degrade and destroy
we investigate one major hack only to
uncover
another one we are particularly
concerned
when nation state adversaries target our
critical infrastructure
and our intellectual property both here
at home and abroad these actors we're
talking about today are alleged to
have developed and deployed
the not petya destructive malware which
wreaked havoc
across the entire globe not petya is
considered one of the most destructive
cyber attacks ever victims included
a hospital in pennsylvania as you've
heard already
the cyber attack crippled that
hospital's operations
i'll not repeat what the u.s attorney
went through
earlier but in the end as he mentioned
that included more than two million
dollars in damages
to a hospital in the state of
pennsylvania
the indictment also alleges this group
was responsible for the olympics
the olympic destroyer malware
which knocked the official 2018 winter
olympics
website offline and prohibited attended
attendees from even being able to gain
their
event tickets these actors conducted
these brazen attacks
from the safety of their own country but
that does not mean
that we should not and will not pursue
them
and hold them accountable whether you're
a cyber criminal turning profit
from hacking or a russian
military intelligence officer who is
intent on taking down
infrastructure these attacks will not
be tolerated we will continue to work in
tandem with our partners
to impose risks and consequences on
these actors however we can
whether it's through indictments or
other means
in this case we brought the
investigative resources and expertise of
three different field offices as you
heard earlier the pittsburgh field
office
of the fbi the atlanta field office of
the fbi
and the oklahoma city field office of
the fbi
we brought them all together to
attribute these attacks to the gru
we also want to thank the nation's tech
giants
which includes google cisco
facebook and twitter for all stepping up
and helping us
with this investigation this is more
common
that we work hand-in-hand with our
private sector partners today than ever
before
we're going to continue to work together
with our partners both at home and
abroad
in law enforcement and in the private
sector to stop brazen cyber crime
and hold these people accountable
one thing i do want to take time to do
is thank
the fbi agents and analysts and those
employees that worked
very diligently on this investigation
i also want to take the time to thank
all the assistant united states
attorneys
and from a headquarters perspective the
department of justice here and the fbi
headquarters cyber division
personnel who worked very tireless on
tirelessly on these
this investigation these investigations
as i've mentioned before
they are arduous and they take diligence
and they take tenacity to get them over
the finish line
we're not yet there but we are to the
point of indictment and that's why we're
here today the cyber threat continues to
be daunting
but when we bring the right people the
right tools
and the right authorities our
adversaries
we believe are no match to what we can
accomplish
together next up
i'd like to introduce our special agent
in charge of our pittsburgh office
mike chrisman
good afternoon again my name is mike
crissman
i'm the special agent in charge of the
fbi pittsburgh office
i know you've heard a lot about this
investigation already and the great work
being done
by our international partners and our
private sector partners
i wanted to echo those same set
sentiments
i also wanted to thank the department of
justice national security division
and u.s attorney scott brady and his
team in the western district of
pennsylvania
u.s attorney brady and his team have
been proactive
in adopting a global approach
to take down cyber criminal networks
whose impact extends well beyond
pittsburgh
and across the globe for that matter
i would also like to thank fbi
headquarters
and the role the fbi pittsburgh division
played in the investigation
and commend the atlanta and oklahoma
city
fbi offices for their work
multiple field offices multiple
investigations
coming together to form a joint coherent
strategy this investigation
is team fbi at its best it displayed the
exceptional talent and dedication of our
teams in pittsburgh
atlanta and oklahoma city who worked
seamlessly
and spent years tracking these members
of the gru
i can't say enough about the work of
these three offices agents in pittsburgh
utilizing cutting-edge investigative
techniques and analytics
to secure the charges that we're
discussing here today
charges that were made possible by
leveraging the tremendous
experience and expertise of agents in
atlanta
regarding energy and the not petya
attacks
as well as the expertise of agents in
oklahoma city
regarding russian gru actors
the gru is a persistent adversary
actively engaging in espionage and
destructive attacks
these cyber attacks are unmatched in
their destructive manner
and disregard for public safety and
innocent victims
in fact not pecha was the most
destructive cyber attack in history
with approximately 10 billion in damages
and over 300 victims worldwide
this case demonstrates what's possible
when international
private sector and law enforcement
partners all work together
together we are uniquely positioned to
identify criminal actors
and overcome obstacles posed by borders
and boundaries
going forward the fbi will continue
coordinated efforts
and commit to combating these threats
through enhanced global partnerships
intelligence dissemination and shared
expertise and resources
thank you
uh thank you mr demers can you tell me
about the timing of this news conference
today these
attacks have long been attributed to the
gru
so does is there a significance to the
timing of these charges coming just
two weeks before the u.s presidential
election no
not particularly in that regard uh you
know we undertake these investigations
as the
deputy director said they take quite
some time as you can see from these
posters we don't attribute them to
countries or
military intelligence units we attribute
them to individuals in those countries
and
when the investigation has matured and
we're ready according to the principles
of federal prosecution then we bring the
cases
our next question is from eric tucker
with the associated press
that 96 is currently in custody and i
apologize if i if i missed discussion of
that earlier
and can you and this might be for you mr
demers or somebody else
talk a little bit about the legal
framework that allows the justice
department to
bring charges against hacks that are on
non-american
targets well what we're charging is a
conspiracy
that conspiracy uh conducted a series of
computer intrusions that harmed american
victims and american companies
and then as part of that conspiracy we
can charge uh
overt acts of that conspiracy that also
uh were targeted and affect people in
other countries
i don't know scott
from reuters will that be the next
question
yeah thank you for doing this um i just
wanted to ask
about a component of this news that was
talked about
by british colleagues who mentioned that
the
2021 summer games was also being
targeted by these hackers
i didn't notice that in the indictment
and i wanted to know
if justice department was aware of this
targeting that's more recent thank you
well i think at this press conference
we're going to stick to what we've
charged which is
you know back into the into the winter
games and
we'll take them as they come
next question from jake gibson from fox
hello can you hear me yes all right
sorry
um so is there any uh evidence i know it
probably is not
part of this indictment but i figured i
should ask anyway do you have any
evidence about
a gru actively trying to um
to hack or to uh you know negative
actions towards the 2020 american
elections
well that you know as you said that's
not part of this indictment
uh with respect to the elections that
are coming up
you know we haven't seen anything that
uh costs us to question
what we've i think repeatedly said and
what the intelligence community has
repeatedly said that americans should be
confident
that a vote cast for their candidate
will be counted for that candidate
next question is andy with cbs
hi thanks for the question um going off
what was just asked actually
um a lot of private industry computer
folks
talk about san warm um which is this
unit being a big concern
coming up on this election in the u.s
and i'm wondering um
i know what john i heard what you just
said obviously but is there any evidence
or have you guys taken any action
against san
more related groups um in the last few
weeks or months
well i'm not going to go beyond what i
just said in that regard
thanks though our last question will be
from
this is anywhere in the 50 page
indictment still working right through
the way through it but can you talk
about what
facebook and twitter did to help with
this
i don't know if they don't want to do
that or
i'll take it listen we're not going to
get into specifics of what the
uh companies do uh to help us um
sorry we're not going to get into
specifics of what the companies do to
help us
i will simply leave it at they did help
us
in a very significant manner which we
are
fortunate enough to enjoy that
partnership
in more and more cyber investigations
this now concludes the formal press
conference all cameras will now be
turned off
we will then have our
you